I'm Sienna Cregg
I'm an anthropologist who teaches and
works at Dartmouth College I'm a medical
anthropologist so I focus on
generally speaking cross-cultural
approaches to health and illness global
health women's and children's health and
I work in Tibetan Himalaya I've been
very fortunate in my career so far that
I've had the opportunity to live and
work in Lhasa and to be in the Tibet
Autonomous Region as well as in qinghai
province Tibetan area and to have this
long-standing relationship with Nepal
there are extremely different political
climates and social worlds really but
they also have a lot of similarities in
terms of the challenges that are facing
regions today living and working in
Lhasa involves a fair amount of
self-censorship and a navigation of
daily life that always feels constrained
and yet there's so much creativity and
wonderful work being done there as well
it's just that it's very understated I
felt very fortunate to be working in
some of the premier Tibetan medical
hospitals in China and to see the the
depth of knowledge of the practitioners
there as well as the real care and
attention put forward toward the future
of Tibetan medicine under great
constraint in Nepal I would say the same
is true but they're working with
different constraints they're the
doctors that I work with are struggling
to be recognized in a state context that
has historically marginalized them and
the people and communities from which
they come and they are trying to figure
out their own place in a shifting not
just political landscape but in economic
one in both cases there are questions
about future generations but I would say
in Nepal the questions about whether or
not or in what way a new generation of
practitioners will emerge is a more
difficult one than in that in the
Tibetan region in part because
in Tibet there are institutions that
people can now belong to and imagine a
career path in whereas in Nepal that's
much more difficult Tibetan medicine is
incredibly adaptive there is I would say
a core set of theories theoretical
principles and texts that relate to
those principles that stretch from the
refugee communities in South India all
the way to Mongolia Buryatia and into
the West and Tibetan doctors practicing
there so there is a something that is
shared or something that is communicable
across all of these domains and yet in
each space we're so Arriba or the the
science of healing as it's often
translated from the Tibetan is practiced
there's a huge amount of variety
variation in practices variation in
local lineage based traditions that
inform how practice is done how
medicines are made and then there is
perforce a huge amount of variation in
the materia medica that is used Tibetan
medicine has a very complex and
incredibly adaptive set of principles
for how you substitute things if you
can't find X well you look for something
that is y that has the same role or
taste and post digestive taste potency
and those things also can cross species
as well so you could have a plant that
that at the level of tastes and potency
is mimicked by an animal product or the
other way around in many ways it is
possible to be a trans Himalayan doctor
to travel between worlds really between
the Nepal or the Indian Himalaya and the
Tibetan Plateau but it is tricky
especially the translation or travel
between India and China people find
spaces to meet doctors from Dharamsala
and other areas of the Tibetan exile
community and those from China have in
recent years been able to come together
in conference formats or in other
settings and share notes
about their historical trajectories talk
about the common problems that they face
especially around the standardization of
practice of Education and the problems
that are arising from the scaling up of
Industry around Tibetan medicine and
what that means for the materia medica
that the that the tradition depends on
folks from Nepal though have in some
senses more ability to move back and
forth across the border or at least they
they have I've had many doctors from
Nepal come and visit institutions in
Lhasa and visit institutions in shining'
which is the capital of Ching hai
province but they are more constrained
usually financially and so that travel
is dependent on a network of sponsorship
and and relationships that aren't quite
as constraining as it is for colleagues
in China so on the one hand Tibetan
medicine is becoming a global commodity
it's very much a commodity in East Asia
and it's becoming much more so in Europe
and North America and Japan on the other
hand Tibetan medicine is still the
frontline of health care for many many
people across the Tibetan Plateau in the
Himalaya and there's a fair amount of
dissonance in those two realities in
many ways Tibetan medicine could be
viewed as something that stitches a very
large and very diverse community
together that said the Tibetan medicine
that you find in Ladakh is going to be
quite different than the Tibetan
medicine you find in Bhutan but yes
there is a certain commitment to ways of
viewing the body ways of understanding
what it means to be ill why you get ill
which is you know it's it's a it's a
very basic human set of principles and
concerns really but it does provide a
kind of vocabulary both an embodied
vocabulary and a spoken one and a
written one that that can in many ways
provide a connection across this this
very diverse area to be a Himalayan
healer in a place like Mustang Nepal
where I've worked now for many years
requires a huge array of skills and
abilities it's not just that you are
capable of getting up at 4:00 in the
morning because someone has come to call
and their mother is sick and you get on
your horse and you ride off to help that
person with your little bag of of
powders and pills it's also that you
come back from that early morning
adventure and you sit down and you try
with your nephew or your cousin to write
an email in English to the sponsor who
has paid for the new roof on your school
to communicate needs that go well beyond
medicine it also means that you have to
wear many hats in the course of village
life you have to participate in all of
the expected rituals and other daily
rules that that are required of you as
you know either a monk or la tantric
household or priest in the context of
Mustang but you also have to be
attentive to so many other needs and
questions you have to you have to also
be thinking about the future of the
people that you're training and how
different their world is and their
professional and adult life will be from
the world that you've grown up in and
are quite comfortable navigating one of
the things I would really like to
continue to pursue in my work over the
coming decade or so is to try to track
and understand and productively engage
with communities and people that I've
known now for many years from Nepal who
are now living in places as nearby as
New York and in other parts of the world
in other parts of South Asia and to
think with them about what it means to
have a sense of trans local home at this
point that what this means for an aging
population who now might not might have
financial security but might not have
their family with them anymore what this
means for a new generation of young
people who are growing up with an
allegiance to a place like Mustang but
once or twice removed how they
understand their place in this
that place and at the same time my
interest in in these processes connect
back to my core interests in health and
illness I'm very curious about what the
future of Tibetan medicine will be in
the places where I've been working for a
long time but also how people in places
like New York navigate and make sense of
health and illness issues in this very
new set of circumstances